we made like 100 million doctors
appointments for ourselves in one week
after this we won't have to go to the
doctor for like 10 years
because we're smart
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to also i had a
banana on the way over here
sorry
i get why you don't want anyone to know
about duke silver and you don't have to
worry
your secret is safe with me
to even it out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's not necessary i once forgot to
brush my teeth for five weeks i didn't
actually sell my last car i just forgot
where i parked it i don't know who al
gore is and at this point i'm too afraid
to ask when they say two percent milk i
don't know what the other 98 is when i
was a baby my head was so big scientists
did experiments on me i once threw a
beard a swan and then it attacked my
niece rebecca
whoa
there's a lot of brain power in this
room we got michael and oscar the two
smartest guys in the office also in that
order
funny jim that is funny very comedically
humorous jim i have a computer question
hey oscar what is it can you move aside
so that i can ask michael all right all
right i get it michael how do i create a
new tab try
control p that's prince not if the
printer isn't hooked up you are making
some very dangerous assumptions oscar
oscar i must be killing you now that
michael is smarter than you he's
he's not smarter than me he was just
right about one thing yeah but it was a
really smart thing to be right about
actually actually
it was around here oscar is known as
actually because he will insert himself
into just about any conversation to add
facts or correct grammar actually you're
speculating there he really does fit
that old stereotype of the smug gang
mexican can you believe this scully
looks like we're the only responsible
people who show up on time anymore and
they're always calling us lazy but where
are they now i don't see them they're
not here but you know who is hitchcock
and scully the oafs the bozos the idiots
what are you doing here the building's
being fumigated there were so many
emails there were we did
lightweight that's your takeaway you've
all been given a specific role and a
code name rosa you're the dagger sarge
the hammer amy the hall monitor yeah
suck it scully and hitchcock i'm just
gonna call you your real name so you
don't get confused smart what
we're sorry that we missed your party
well don't worry about it you all have
stuff to do yes the capital of ecuador
is quito oh anyway
happy birthday from all of us thanks
guys you you're the best
i can't believe it the fake birthday
worked
you're a genius we're both geniuses
thumb jack
that was my thumbtack
anyway uh it is now my great honor to
welcome to the stage the woman
responsible for the entire harvest
festival ladies and gentlemen leslie
knope
every one of you just by showing up here
tonight
has already made history in days past
the harvest festival was the cornerstone
of pawnee's small business community a
week-long showcase for everything from
textiles to small farms
by our estimates as many as thirty 000
people might attend the festival and the
monetary value of that kind of direct
customer to business exposure is frankly
incalculable
the time is now
the place is pawnee
let's make history
that was amazing that was a flu-ridden
michael jordan at the 97 nba finals that
was
kirk gibson hobbling up to the plate and
hitting a homer off of dennis eckersley
that was
that was leslie knope
thank you so much any questions
yes sir
are we going to get the same sales tax
incentives we used to that's a very good
question sir and i would counter with my
own question which is
why is half of your face all swirly okay
um unfortunately leslie has another very
important meeting right now so if you
have any other questions you can just
direct them uh towards me give it up
everybody for scott bakula from quantum
leap all right okay hey so this isn't
matching up with this and i'm not sure
which one's right can you just hunt down
the original part yes me do all right
hey kev what were you saying before
about the paperwork
we doing now
go stop worry
kevin do you feel okay me feel good body
strong sleep big last night yeah i think
we should get him to the hospital yeah
all right kid why don't you come with us
no no no no he's fine fine he's always
been like that no he hasn't i mean he's
gotten worse over the years he's making
a statement it's an ironic comment on
our expectations of him
a fun house image of our model of kevin
you keep think that
me mechanic not speak english but he
know what me mean when me say car no go
and we best friends so me think why
waste time say lot word when few words
do trick
kevin i
appreciate what you're trying to do dank
here we have a word code
the same way we have a dress code and
what we're talking about is
basically the speech equivalent
to just wearing underpants
sometimes words
you know need use
but need need for talk talk
but save time more success does it save
time though because we've been here for
about an hour no me fault
kevin at most you're saving a
microscopic amount of time
many small time make big time
what are you gonna do with all this time
sea world kevin you can't possibly save
enough time to see the world kevin are
you saying see the world or sea world
sea world
oceans fish
jump okay china no see right there
that's the problem with your method
because i still don't know if you're
saying sea world or see the world and
it's taken a lot of time to explain it
fine
fine i'll talk normally
when me president
they see
they see
the two hunks have arrived hi
so glad to have you here dad happy to be
here
how was your flight oh good good you
know i did the times crossfire oh great
puzzle today right oh my god 17 down uh
i know what about 16 across what about
34 across oh what about 45 down what
about 20 across
i also did it yeah so here's a letter
that the arsonist sent to then
your clues i discombobulate to teach you
to conjugate the fool who fails to
validate will watch as i conflagrate it
seems like it's using my crossword to
tell me something oh maybe we should
look at anagrams of the answers that's
really good old nasty amiga the how what
he rearranged the letters of amy
santiago he anagrammed me then do jake
peralta all right that's even possible
eat a jerk pal what no one's ever said
that phrase i really think this anagram
approach makes a lot of sense seriously
let's do it i'll take even clues you
take
i can't believe you left your post what
the plan wasn't yours so you didn't
think it was worth following well
because of your juvenile behavior one of
our city's finest
abandoned lard factories is now burned
to the ground my gut told me that sam
jepson was setting the fires although
and i realized his actual life is much
sadder than that of a serial arsonist
well we agreed to do vin's plan so what
vin is not a cop why do you keep siding
with him instead of me oh let me guess
because he was right and the building
was on fire and he's perfect wait are
you jealous of vin
jake
all right i didn't want to say anything
because it's a gross emotion but yes i
am a little bit jealous of the super
smart supermodel
this was our last case together and you
and him have been joined at the hip or
in his case that super sexy b muscle
that i don't understand how to tone he
told me it's a lot of bicycle crunches
crunches on a bicycle that's crazy you
would just fall right off babe you have
no reason to be jealous of him
i just
i don't want you to wake up one day and
wish that you were
with someone as smart as you are
i am with someone as smart as i am
you you're a brilliant detective i love
the way you think
that's why i want to marry you
marry me
mary oh my god look the arson is spelled
m-a-r but they were going to spell
m-a-r-r-y or
conjugate conjugate means mary yes and
who wants to marry vin the lady from the
bar
hey puzzle chick unscramble this
you're going to elge
you